my invention is a flower garden with a
hose that never runs out of water this
is my makeup box that I make it for
Mabel she needs help with with some
makeup sometimes every time she gets
messed up with her makeup there either
let's kara under here or under this one
well make my mom not have to go to the
store and buy fruits and veggies you're
just so busy you're doing so many things
sometimes I just wanted a home-cooked
meal on the table every night that I
don't have to make I have these cards at
the back so I can push it and it'll roll
straight to a knowledge she's like oh
look at this little prison in order to
be able to handle a house full of
children and homeschool it's very
challenging so the meantime is what I
don't have
[Music]
[Music]
show me a little bit about what you have
in terms of your idea this big of a
flower garden and then a flower hose
right here of a box everything he is her
makeup sections like carrots put cars
under the wheels
[Music]
how do you envision getting this to her
the cars I'm gonna make this mom she'll
love it
kayla is very outgoing she is the
funniest person I've ever seen I think I
can use this way the house he's so much
fun he's so funny so curious and that's
the beauty of it cuz he just always
wants to learn now I'm gonna start
putting on the road and putting on the
hot wheels these are the harsh going
around the house so I'm gonna make a
hole and then I can put a hose right
there to use and that's a con I'm
standing
[Music]
oh my goodness oh it says mom though
this is where the water comes in from
the rain and the host breeze water out
of it mr. Chasen welcome
you always help tell what to make up
some time okay I do so you wouldn't have
to go to the store and buy fruits and
vegetables I definitely love the
convenience of it rolling up to me
because there's a lot of times when I
need things to go
query quickly yeah oh now that's
creative so first of all he's thinking
of the environment and then within that
there's so many ways to help me because
they're beautiful for this time yep back
and I want to be like you oh I put the
hot wheels on the road to show that I
will they take me on cool trips to new
places I never been to
[Music]